one other but speaking of psychosis by
the way just one other thing so many of
you wrote to me and and told me David
something seems to have happened here
with Mike Lindell also known as as Mike
pillow
um in related to the election because
he's been doing some really really
strange TV appearances where he seems
truly to have lost it he claims he has
all sorts of people who are here or
there or I don't even know where
um yeah it is weird here is a clip in
which my my pillow Mike Lindell from his
airplane says he is somehow monitoring
every race for fraud people we're gonna
be watching every race we're gonna have
the real-time crime deaths going at
Frank speech.com Is that real like what
could they possibly be watching
everybody you can watch me there
tomorrow night
um we are tracking every race by cyber I
want all the bad guys out there to know
through the Edison report we are
watching and we also have another way to
watch what's going on with the computers
in the machine so I'm putting them all
on notice Steve they're all on notice so
that we are by the way you can turn in
at the
crime.frankspeech.com right if you
receive any irregularities you can
report it to pillow you see anything
turn it in there yep
um and people say to me David is that
funny is that sad is it dangerous what
what exactly is that
um Mike pillow appeared
who the hell knows where it's so
difficult to even understand where these
appearances are happening this is
something called Victory I don't even
know what this is here he says you know
he's catching people red-handed this was
as the election results were coming in
last night or I want to bring in Mike
Lindell uh Mike you got some interesting
results you wanted to share go ahead
yeah well first of all when you guys
were talking before I was listening to
you who attacked our country and what is
this all about right it's the CCP the
UNA party the Deep State the globalist
and now the Democrat Party joining with
all of them globalist
um here's what we have in our real-time
crime desk if you have a Graphic to put
up I'm going to show you just one of
them and this is from the Democrat so
we're watching these races Vance was one
did you I don't even know what that was
I mean it did that graphic he put up
meant nothing it says dance was one I
believe they early on they were taking
it uh taking advance and I think they
just didn't put any injection because he
totally overran the algorithm injection
we're watching these races and it's like
real-time crime I caught a crime Spike
and then you get these crime spikes and
but everybody
so listen is that psychosis I have no
idea not qualified to diagnose it it
certainly would be funny if it weren't
sad and more importantly it's extremely
dangerous because he has followers and
in all seriousness I don't understand
how his family can't get him some help
and get him out of this endless loop it
has been years now and pillow has said
I I I miss my time with my family
because I'm flying around doing all this
stuff I'm pouring I think he told me
during our interview 30 something
million into this stuff between lawyers
and Tech and who knows what the hell
else at some point you would think his
family could get him some help but it
does not seem to be happening we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad producer Pat will
join me we are going to zoom out and do
five big picture takeaways from the exit
polls the exit polls yesterday were
really interesting insofar as they asked
people about what do you think about the
direction of the country how did people
vote depending on that
who do you think won the 2020 election
how did people vote depending on that
you can probably guess we're going to
look at takeaways from the exit polls
secondly there is now increasingly the
claim being made Ron DeSantis is the new
Republican party leader Trump didn't
really endorse DeSantis he sort of
begrudgingly did on Monday
and DeSantis very much overperformed and
was re-elected governor meanwhile many
of the people Trump picked lost
so we're going to talk about that and
then we are also going to talk about
where abortion was on the ballot
yesterday it mostly saw voter support
and that is not shocking if you
understand the polling data but
interesting to see in a broader context
all of those stories and much more on
today's bonus show folks this is the
start this is the start of what will be
an insane two years in American politics
which hopefully doesn't end with the end
of democracy okay
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get the
bonus show you'll get commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
you'll be invited to our next member
only Town Hall you can use the brand new
coupon code 24 starts now that's 2-4
starts now no spaces all lower case or
caps doesn't matter 24 starts now also
make sure you're subscribed to our audio
podcast it's on every podcasting
platform whatever you use it's there
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
we are getting started for what is going
to be a major undertaking over the next
two years I'll see you on the bonus show